[Music]
one of the most recognizable landmarks
near Dallas is of course AT&T Stadium
it's home to the Dallas Cowboys and
start here starting this weekend it will
be hosting the NC double-a Final Four
that is very exciting so all this week
to honor the Final Four taking place
here in Texas we're doing what anyone
would do we're shooting full court
baskets outside AT&T Stadium with the
help of a catapult we stole from Mark
Cuban's bedroom it's a full court
three-point shot ladies and gentlemen
not only that instead of shooting a
basketball at a basketball hoop anyone
can do that every night we've been
launching something uniquely Texan so
far we've launched a 72-ounce steak from
the Big Texan we launched a basketball
prodigy just born at Baylor Medical
Center yes its head came off and Willie
Nelson's back taxes we've hit with
tonight we'll be shooting an item that
honors Texas Mexican heritage and its
love of barbecue that's right a pinata
filled with seven pounds of Texas beef
brisket
[Applause]
in the brisket it's ready to go he is a
peerless of four three two
[Applause]
we don't quit in Texas we load the
pinata
for
next item can be found all over the
roads in Texas it's an armadillo that's
been flattened by a truck the armadillo
is still alive it's begging not to go
[Applause]
[ __ ] tango let's see what the referee
says I couldn't tell
let's check with the referee he sang
[Applause]
no that's [ __ ] I say we launch that
a whole referee
don't look too closely cuz it's just a
dummy boy
[Applause]
here's the coolest part we teamed up
with AT&T to bring you our new conan 360
camera it's revolutionary technology
allowing our viewers to watch all of
those catapult shots in 360-degree video
right on their computer tablet or phone
so let's take a look at the conan 360
replay you can see that beautiful Texas
skyline and you can see the board sound
guy you see all the action you can watch
from any shot any angle with this
breakthrough technology so thanks to our
good friends AT&T for bringing you Conan
360 now you'll be able to experience our
show in a whole new way we'll take a
break when we come back